There's been a bunch of new updates to
Claude code and I think at this point
I've stopped using Open Claw most of the
time and I want to talk you through why
that is um and why I think Claude is
actually better at this point versus
open claw. I'll still be doing updates
in the future about open claw and how it
works and that sort of thing. But right
now I would say with the new skills that
Claude has received um with the latest
features etc. There's actually 10 of
them that I'll walk you through. These
updates actually make Claude Code and
Claude in general better and more
powerful than something like OpenClaw in
general, right? You can see, for
example, yesterday they actually
launched inside Claude Code the new
schedule task update and that allows you
to schedule tasks just like you would
with OpenClaw as long as you've got this
running. Um, but it's going to run
locally, is going to do everything that
OpenClaw can do. And the other cool
thing here is it doesn't break, right?
Unlike open claw which is super
technical can be very buggy breaks all
the time struggles to update with claude
you typically do get better outputs and
I've also seen this for example across
the board so if we actually look at
Google trends for example and and we
look at like the growth of open claw
over time you can see it peaked in
demand around about March the 7th right
if we look over like the last uh well
let's have a look let's have a look over
the last month or so something like that
yeah as you can see for example you
know, February the 16th, it really
peaked in demand and um and I think a
lot of people waking up to the
realization that OpenClaw is it was a
really powerful tool, but at the same
time with all the new updates that
coming out to Claude, with all the new
updates that coming out, all the
alternatives and all the competitors to
open claw as well in general, it seems
like there'd be no reason to continue
using OpenClaw unless you really want
something um that's super customizable,
super technical, and you love the
customization of something like
OpenClaw. So I'm going to walk you
through the new updates that have just
come out and and some of the new stuff
you can do. So the biggest one is
obviously schedule tasks came out from
claw to co-work and if you've not seen
this before this is the biggest open
claw comparable feature right so
schedule task allows you to delegate
work to co-work by creating tasks that
run automatically on recurring basis or
on demand. So the way that you do this
is if you're using co-work which is kind
of like the non-technical version of cl
code that works locally what you can
actually do is go to your scheduled
section over here and then you can set
up new tasks that run on demand whenever
you want right so they can run hourly
weekly monthly etc. And you can also do
this inside the chat. You can say here,
okay, create a new schedule task
to check
claw news daily. And then you can say,
okay, working in this folder, set up a
new folder here. Once you set up,
you can create new schedule tasks inside
co-work. Super simple and easy to do.
And the other thing here as well is like
you're not running on API tokens like
you would with open claw. So with open
claw, it can get quite expensive. I
actually spent I've had days where I
spent like $38 on API tokens on uh on
OpenClaw whereas for example with Claude
you just pay for the plan that you want
and then you stick with that for the
month right and and so your costs are
pretty much capped and so here you can
quickly choose okay here's the schedule
task you want and but basically if you
if you want like an easier way to use
the benefits of open claw you can do
that inside claw already and it's the
same for example with claw code so the
second update is that you can do exactly
the same thing inside core code Now claw
code and claw cowork are different. Claw
code is a bit more technical but you can
run it inside here and you can do
schedule tasks and everything else and
then you can run that daily there. The
next one is remote control. Right? So
remote control is basically a new
feature that bridges your local claude
code terminal sessions with claude AI
code, the claude iOS app and the claude
Android app. Right? So your session
keeps running on your machine the entire
time and the web and mobile interface is
just a window into your local session.
This is huge. Right? So you can
basically offer a clawed code from
wherever you are and this is very
similar to openclaw in the way that you
can connect it to telegram. So the way
that you would do this is for example if
we were running the session um in cycl
code like so we can type for slash
remote
control and then we can start using the
remote control um version of claw code
and basically access claw code on our
mobile device. You just have to enable
it and it depends what account you're
on. Like for example, for me, this is an
a business team account. But if we were
using a personal account, you would just
use for/ remote control and then you
could access the cloud code session
running locally on your device via
mobile or via any other device you set
up. Also, there's auto memory inside um
inside claw code, right? So anthropic is
allowed automemory which is kind of like
open claw in the fact that it can
remember what you've done previous
sessions etc. So if we go into claw code
here and we say okay
what did I do on previous sessions
basically you've got auto memory that
you can you can quickly access and you
can you can see across previous sessions
to see what happened and it
automatically remembers stuff right and
it can save notes to your memory files.
So you see how it it can recall memories
over here. Now also what you've got here
is you can import from chat GPT Gemini
and Copilot. So this was a new update on
March 26th um on March 2nd 2026. And
basically what you can do is you can
import your memory from other tools like
chat GPT and Gemini and you can import
those directly into Claude. Now that's
not really like an open claw feature but
it basically means that if you're using
other AI tools you can import that
directly into Claude and use um the
previous customizations from other AI
agents so you can remember what you've
done previously. And then also there's a
bunch of new stuff inside the free
plans. So for example a lot of people
like open claw because it's free but you
can use for example connectors now for
free inside claude which basically makes
it you know a similar level to open claw
in the way that it can connect to other
platforms. So
basically they added connectors which
means that you can set up apps inside
claude. So if we go to claude here and
when I write add connectors you can add
different apps with one click using
claude um and then connect it to
different tools externally as well. And
if you click on manage connectors here,
you can add even more. So you can add
like custom connectors and that sort of
thing. And you can do that via the web
or you can do that via desktop as well.
And then of course they're always
releasing new models. I mean the best
models to use in open core anyway are
like Opus 4.6 and Sonic 4.6. So if
you're going to use those models and you
want a non-technical way of using them
without paying the API cost as well,
then you can just use claw code directly
instead of open core. And uh the final
thing I'll say here is like you know
claude is is growing massively. They're
now the number one uh free iOS app in
the app store, a spot normally held by
chat GBT. That's come down to some other
stuff related to this, but it's still an
amazing product. So, just to recap, the
big picture here is that Claude is now
doing natively what open claw required a
full setup to achieve. So, for example,
autonomous loops, you can do scheduled
tasks inside claw code and co-work for
background um execution. Co-work runs
whilst you step away. Same with claw
code. Remote access from phone. You can
now do remote control from iOS and
Android. computer control. So co-work
runs in local um virtual manager with
file system access. And for third party
integrations, you can use MCP connectors
or just those connectors I've talked
about previously. So for example, Slack,
Gmail, Google Drive. And for memory
persistence, you've got auto memory
inside CL code. And you've got the
import tool from chat GPT and everything
else. And finally, the other thing you
can do here is you can actually
coordinate sub agents in the same way
that you do that on open core. You can
do that inside claw code as well. So the
key difference is really between open
claw and claude it's like claude makes
this easier. It's a bit more friendly
for nontechnical people. There's no
technical setup whereas something like
open claw you need server configuration
docker API keys etc. So that's the
difference between both of these and
that's why I'm beginning to use uh claw
code and claude in general a lot more
than open. So thanks so much for
watching. If you do want to get my best
trainings on Claude and Open Claw, you
can do that inside the AI profitboarding
link in the comments description or just
go to the AI profitboarding.com. This is
my AI automation community with 2,600
members. Basically, it's focused on
helping you save time, scale, and learn
AI automation. Inside the community, you
can ask questions, you can get help, you
can get support whenever you need to.
You can also see there's a daily
accountability group so you can stay
laser focused on your goals. I do a
weekly update. So I condense all of my
research down from 60 hours of research
a week into like a quick five minute
update that you can read and people
absolutely love it. As you can see right
here, people are um finding it super
useful. So that helps filter the noise.
And then also inside the calendar you
get weekly coaching calls. You can check
out the map and see what's happening in
your local area, meet people in your
local area, etc. And then inside the
classroom here, you can get all of my
best training. So, for example, you can
go from beginner to expert with AI
automation and learn how to build your
first AI agent in under five minutes.
You can also, for example, get my best
playbooks I personally use. So, if you
want to learn how I automate avatar
videos, Instagram shorts, newsletters,
X, etc., you can learn that right here.
If you want to get my best updates on,
for example, the new stuff that comes
out. So, for example, yesterday we
tested out Kilo Claw, Perplexica, Star
Office UI, Perplexi Skills, Notebook,
etc. Every day we create new guides and
new video tutorials based on the latest
stuff. We're actually one of the most
active AI communities in the world
because we're constantly updating this
with the newest, most useful stuff that
you can have. And we have a full six
hour course on how to use Open Core,
plus another 3-hour course right here to
help you. If you want to learn how to
get more clients, you can check out the
agency course. If you want to uh watch
back the coaching course, you can do
that here. If you want to learn how to
rank number one with AICO, you can do
that. And then also if you want to for
example grow your YouTube channel based
on what's working for me, you can check
that out here. So that's all inside the
arprofit boardroom link in the comments
description or go to the
arprofitboarding.com. The other thing
I'll say is we have over 134 pages of
testimonials, happy people getting great
results inside these communities. So if
you want to learn the stuff and you want
to see what's possible, you can see a
lot of the wins right here and you can
see how people are achieving stuff and
and what sort of stuff they're getting
um right here. So, it's pretty amazing
to see people and the impact that we're
doing with this